para washington ya no hay nada que
negociar mientras se esperaba que irán y
eeuu respondieran a lo que la unión
europea denominó como texto final con el
objetivo de revivir el acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 el departamento de estado de
eeuu ha advertido a teherán de que no se
exceda y si la única manera de lograr un
retorno mutuo al cumplimiento del
acuerdo de bien es que irán abandone
otras demandas inaceptables que van más
allá del alcance de ese acuerdo
hace tiempo que calificamos estas
exigencias de superfluas
instruments la unión europea redactó la
propuesta la semana pasada afirmando que
ya no había más plazo para negociar o
llegar a un compromiso durante más de un
año el bloque ha facilitado los diálogos
indirectos para intentar salvar el
acuerdo de viena después de que el
retiro unilateral de eeuu en 2018
durante la administración de donald
trump pusiera al pacto en peligro de
muerte ahora irán quiere garantías de
que ninguna otra administración podrá
retirarse de un posible nuevo acuerdo
aunque esto podría resultar complicado
ya que el acuerdo no es jurídicamente
vinculante si eeuu demuestra que está
dispuesto a ser flexible y realista
entonces en los próximos días podremos
llegar a un acuerdo pero si no no es el
fin del mundo
el acuerdo de viena pretende frenar el
programa nuclear de irán a cambio de un
alivio a las sanciones de eeuu la unión
europea y la onu los analistas creen que
teherán y washington tienen razones de
peso para mantener vivo el pacto pero
admiten que ninguna de las partes está
dispuesta a hacer concesiones